what's up everyone we're here to talk to
you today about a thing we've been
working on called tether I'm sure all
you guys have watched this video and
been like where did this come from
what is this about we're about to tell
you the story of what this is all about
right after we finished creating our
modern warfare series we had our sights
set at creating another long-form web
series that first concept was tether
created nearly two years ago so he
created a bunch of different storylines
made this whole universe bunch of
concept art trying to set up this world
so we could make a neat web series in
but at the end of the day things didn't
really work out and we instead focused
on our YouTube channel making the
bi-weekly content that you guys are so
familiar with so as you guys saw we made
Minecraft we made a bunch of stuff I'm a
dubstep Gunz all that stuff last year
until we were reappraise again that is
where this particular episode comes in
so this is what we made a pilot for
tether a potential first episode that
would give you guys a taste of what the
full series could be like so machinima
now having grown in our channel having
grown approached this again to try
making a webseries one more time we
wrote a script came up with all this
stuff for the pilot but once again
things didn't work out but at this point
it is something we put so much time into
in a world that we had spent so much
time crafting that we're like yeah we're
gonna do it anyways we want to make a
short film so you guys can at least see
what we were trying to try and make
trying to conjure out of thin air now
you know actually making it is easier
said than done I mean the script
requires tons of actors locations
vehicles gunfights VFX just tons of
stuff and that obviously required a
budget so what we decided to do is fund
it out of our own pockets and make it
ourselves a true corridor digital
production from the ground up so as you
guys can tell there's still a lot of
mystery and unsolved enigmas in this
world of tether that we have not yet
explained we don't know if were gonna
make one more generally speaking it's
whenever we go back to Minnesota for
Christmas that we shoot an episode of
tether this year if you guys really like
this and you want to see another one
we'll probably throw up a Kickstarter so
you guys can help us pull off one more
episode to round out the world like
giving us a Christmas present that we
then give back to you
after messing with it a little bit so I
hope you guys like tether now I know
it's just a little taste of this giant
world hopefully down the line we make
another one and you guys like it yeah
and especially considering everyone's
positive response to sync so far we
really wanted to give making another
long-form narrative series a shot
whether it's Heather or something
different not sure kind of up to you but
either way make sure it something you
guys want to watch
so anyway section checking it out
Facebook Twitter it's also needing
integration